ah said I'm still watching I'm so sorry
welcome on is B today we're gonna play a
bunch of games and it's gonna be the
best you're not listening the video just
started and you're not warning this game
is hard oh wow
wait this is this is my face application
how did this get here dan dan Wow
oh did you see that no god I'm getting
so [ __ ] sick of these shut up [ __ ]
wait what why are you why are you gonna
zoom in did I see that see what yes I
saw it
there was a triangle in his anus what
hahahaha okay I call that [ __ ] see I
know Illuminati when I see one
gaben oh lord gaben we're getting rare
lord gaben you've answered my prayers
all this time I I didn't think you were
real please let me borrow your one of
your chins Oh God what the [ __ ] alright
I'm dead I don't wanna play anymore
people say I play bad games but games
aren't good if there is a life break it
down now to me now girl break it down
now coming out girl break it down down
with my girl the ginger bus - good
alright what am i doing I need to not
drink coffee ever
a backwards okay what is happening why
am I doing this
oh [ __ ] that's gotta hurt my junior
mustache I wonder if it's a real junior
mustache or a phone pay come ginger
mustache get life boyfriend bar yes
please start Saturday the time of the
week again when most of the people you
know are out there somewhere probably
having fun and you're home alone
wondering just what to do with the
precious few hours of freedom from the
cubicle there's always plenty of things
going on movies to see friends to visit
but then there's also the other thing
GATS have needs muttered what are you
gonna do it's pretty clear you won't
find that with friends TV or video games
so back to the boyfriend bar Destin
alright you descent the crummy stairs
ring the bell and wait for the doorman
to let you in back to this temp again
okay 30k [ __ ] music David three away dad
disco me someday Arvind alright alright
think I'm life is too short to play some
games not being homophobic I just
genuinely don't have any interest must
dash formerly known as punch - why they
got copyrighted is that a big that's
supposed to be a baby baby where are you
going don't escape I'll kill you oh god
what it wait that's punch mustaches on
that woman oh sure may I say you that's
quite a beautiful baby you have there
would be shame if anything happened
hahahahahaha she doesn't even care so I
get points for punching mustaches on
people rich face best best game homo
station no mustache I got a moustache a
moustache a moustache dude my face
I got about thing but my second
Gonzalez I look like a look like a
smiley face
Oh what's the baby's name Alex its
Gonzalez rah rah you're Gonzalez you're
Burbage Gonzalez you're now that's
inappropriate
darling I am Lord Lord of the aisle none
shall pass
I must block the passers-by until they
go back to wherever they come from yes
this is my aisle this is my homeland
excuse me sir where do you think you're
going on get back to where you come from
you racist son of a [ __ ] go back white
boy go back to where you came from
hey Oh what what do you wanna do get
milk you can get milk from your mama's
tits go home that's right
I may be bald and I look like Santa but
I still know how to moonwalk like a boss
faceless ghosts who are these faces go
trying to pass through my lands
I shall use my power to smite them Basia
my I'll play P P P P
you shall not pass my underwear is older
than you that's probably true and it's
kinda gross respect the elder for no
reason at all you you go go go go no one
likes you
hey no no no yeah I built my castle
walls to keep everyone else
oh this is my castle ha ha ha this games
brilliant eh Oh where's some clothes
woman began as part of sat on I may be
bald and I may not have functional
nipple
but I have courage and you shall not
pass Oh barbarians gate all there
towards seeking Paget's have come to
talk to my weary bones some I'm really
just a senile old man Sargon there's
only one Lord of the island and it's
Santa Claus no they're too many they're
too many ah no
now the Beckham demons they never end
the waves of the horde never ends final
siege the walls are in shambles I'll
need some reinforcements who can I count
on but myself I must fight to keep from
man this game attack my minions protect
thy homeland none shall pass oh oh my
god oh my god we're doing it we're doing
it we're doing it good suck my ass oh no
no oh no someone slip pass Gandalf all
the hopes dreams and friends of your
younger days eventually pass you by alas
you cannot stop the passage of time my
old friend
that's sad scheme is sad I was just I
was just an old man looking for a way to
find adventure again it's been so long
since I felt so accelerated but I guess
every man needs to face the truth if you
don't milk your nipples every day
they're gonna become all saggy and weird
remember that keep rows while you're
still young this may be my last message
but that doesn't mean I shut I don't
[ __ ] it no one gonna do some fry a
Indies vs. PewDiePie games cuz there's
still a lot of good ones ha ha ha ha
best trick ever
you can't catch what is more fabulous
than you you'll never get me a lie
please do get me alive actually I don't
want to die I just want to run naked oh
god stay the mask is coming after me ah
[ __ ]
Teddy space fears day care what the [ __ ]
look at me
how many people are playing this dammit
falcon lover simulator hahaha wow so
this is how he makes me this is how I
make videos oh my god this is best best
gaming hahahaha oh it's in Africa of
course yes
oh let's see if we can score and yes
nail a oh all right fun things to do
dance
alright um at the Koala tile of this I'm
probably hey I threw a hot dog to it
alright alright that's that's a lot of
games we play today I hope you had fun
with me I had a lot of fun playing with
you thank you for watching as always I
really appreciate it seriously though
thank you you're cool you're cool I mean
you're okay like don't let it get to
your head or anything like that
thanks for leaving it like it's always
diet